the 20s are not equal for men and women
right your early 20s
18 to 22 very equal graduate
college work enter the real world have
fun get crazy do stupid things it's all
great
your early 20s as a woman you could take
a few years 21 22 23. by the time you're
24 25
something needs to go off to say okay i
can't just it's time like hoe it up out
there much longer
for a guy
take all the time you want
waste your 20s
waste your mid-20s waste your late 20s
waste your early 30s
it's a lot
different why
biologically women need to start having
kids by the time they're in their early
30s give or take some women can wait a
little bit longer some women okay men
you see men having kids in their 40s 50s
i just met a guy who said that his dad
just had a kid he was like 72. that's
insane
but it's possible
there's no ladies out there it's like
yeah i'm a grandma i just had a kid too
it's like no you didn't grandma that's
my those are my twins so what you're
saying is very important natalia
a woman has to realize the mate and who
they're gonna be with and getting their
[ __ ] together way quicker than a guy
it's no secret
women mature faster than men
there's no secret that men tend to date
younger more attractive women
because it's just kind of part of
culture and i think it's a kind of a
good thing that men do date younger
women because now i'm like you know kids
but like younger women because it does
mature woman after that relationship
when i dated him um my next relationship
was very much like
a mature it was a it was a great
relationship you know what was up you
were like i was like you can be you
could be the future you're okay yeah
yeah but you're good enough buddy you're
kind of yeah yeah you're done
yeah you said you're 44. yeah you've
never been married never been married no
kids no kids what's your longest
relationship
i lived
i've lived with a couple girls for like
four years okay
have you ever dated a girl who made
significantly more than you
significantly more than me uh in l.a but
not not like
crazy but i had some girls what's the
most where it's like okay i made x and
she was
what was that power dynamic i'll say
like
like how much i don't even know the
amounts but like
she made 20 more than you 50 more she
was super successful she was she was a
hollywood actress and she was killing it
she was
i this girl was one of the
early ones that were doing that webcam
whatever it was weird okay i'm not
judging whatever but she was just
balling bro just had money yeah like
it's one of those videos where you you
hear the girl you're here
just perverts it like nebraska like yeah
drooling over my girl yeah wearing
lingerie and it wasn't nothing crazy but
um but just you know making money it
just it was awkward for me because
you know
to you know she was gifting all the time
and i'll take this and take my card
i knew it wasn't going to work out
because i couldn't have that yeah that
dichotomy didn't work i couldn't have
her be that did that affect your mental
100 and don't get me wrong i was still
making money but yeah she was so like
just here and take this and uh and it
sucks well how many how many times would
you be like
no no you're like
all right i'll take the car you know
what i mean like so the relationship
because you've had other relationships
where you've been more the
breadwinner the earner yeah i was paying
the right and you're paying the rent and
the girl there's a due that power
dynamic does that work a little bit
better i i feel like uh
eq
i feel like that with the dude this is
my my personal experience if the guy is
kind of in charge taking the reins yeah
dude don't be wrong have your career do
your thing make your money have the kids
but my mom was a g worked raised three
kids my dad never changed bro my dad
never picked up her legs wiped her none
of that it was old old school middle
eastern so you know to have a woman that
you know you know does her thing and
whatever but still i i think the
you have to let the guy be the guy you
feel me like just attitude and i'm not
saying be like hey i'm in charge of the
[ __ ] house but you got to let them be
the first men lead women following yeah
this is what they this yeah that's why
you know men i mean and obviously being
a man now it's male masculine toxic
whatever the [ __ ] it's like bro we're
dudes we have testosterone like we came
from like neanderthals that's [ __ ] give
me your best neanderthal you're about to
do it
like
i always said this did that well back in
the day like like in the caveman days
like how did if like if a caveman saw a
girl with no language did he just go ugh
like one of the caves
and she was like
[Music]
a club
um
hey eric how much time we got left buddy
we got 15 minutes thanks derek
um
his name was eric yeah but sometimes you
know it's there
whatever sometimes he can be a d head so
yeah but we love that guy
none of this would be possible without
that guy um the reason that i have this
this conversation because it goes down
back to the concept of hypergamy the
concept of hypergamy is
the act of dating up or marrying up your
socio-economic class women do this it's
been stated that women
will only
be serious or date with men
across or above them
meaning if a woman's making 50 grand
she'll date a guy making 50 and all the
way up i agree she ain't dating some
dude that's working to counter
mcdonald's for 12 dollars an hour
fax
a guy
if he's making 50 grand he'll date
whatever and whatever
like no matter what yeah so
the
like
amber heard
successful you know natalia said you
know she's kind of doing her come up
thing she's not going to date some
schlub she's only going to go after guys
equal yeah or johnny depp
on the atmosphere
so that that that's kind of part of the
concept that i'm talking about here
because
and we've alluded to this
but i'll just say it again the johnny
depp amber heard thing
we're not obsessed with it because it's
them
it's because it's all of us
that are dating women out of our league
men out of our league younger hotter
women older more
uh
put together men
monies involved who's paying divorce
settlements
we get drunk fights arguments
this is the society that we live in
today
it's just amplified because it's
hollywood vibes but there's a lot of
this that goes on with
with with all of everybody bro this is
this isn't this isn't like a out of the
blue oh my god people have shitty
relationships i mean yeah it's it's
weird i think i might have mentioned
this in the bullpen like a week ago i'm
like notice how this is what i remember
the o.j what dude it was murder and it
was it was insane mystery what this
guy's racist holy [ __ ] notice how this
is on tv every single day we've been
watching it for how long i don't know
who gives it the okay what who says okay
let's do it we talked about gelane
maxwell did you even see her the trial
there was no cameras no nothing mind you
she was the groomer for this piece of
[ __ ] i've seen had the island all these
people all this well i didn't see her
one time it was sketches of delay
maxwell but this was on tv every day and
it's what we want nobody gives a [ __ ]
about glee maxwell i do i would rather
have seen that yeah like who would you
have on the island where all these
people give me the [ __ ] names were
all these people that had sex with all
these that's not what the media wanted
no it's no [ __ ] because guess what a lot
of elite [ __ ] names they might
have been on there they might get called
out